on va jouer tout de suite à touche pas à
mon post it c'est parti on y va plutôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir comment sur ma joie et grégoire
grégoire attention tu as 20 secondes
pour trouver qui est cette personne qui
est sur ton front d'accord attention
c'est parti
top est ce que c'est une femme
non non tu peux que non c'est pas d'un
dom oui ce qu'un homme s'est tué une
femme c'est dans l'anneau politique non
un acteur non parce que c'est une
célébrité
oui très célèbre très célèbre ville est
hockey de notre époque
oui c'est un génie un chanteur je sais
plus non et c'est pas moi c'est non 21
c'est eux
voilà j'ai perdu c'est alors lui alors
n'ont jamais trouvé comme toi tu invites
j'ai quand même gagné ritary veut rien à
ce qui arrive de rien vous attention
joséphine attention vous allez jouer
attention c'est parti
vingt secondes joséphine ces parties où
l'art est ce que je suis une femme mais
est ce que je suis de notre époque
oui est-ce que je suis une artiste non
non non ferreux l'éthique est ce que je
suis
il ya d'autres choses que des artistes
je suis donc une présentatrice télé
est ce que je suis et bim des liens
regardez qui vous êtes regarde regarde
et que vous êtes l effet karine le
marchand
alors pour vous tout se passe bien a
maintenant à vous jean michel maire
venait là jean miché meilleure attention
attention c'est parti pour 20 secondes
jean michel maire si ça se passe mal
bien sûr je ferai jouer la table
attention c'est parti tôt je suis un
homme non et aux bas donc une femme
politique de notre temps oui kim sera
vendredi dans touche non non non qui
encore au ministre il est politique et
journalistique qui est qui et de la
politique we will keane bah oui c'est
joli
[Applaudissements]
tant pis je vois bien la marque elle
même au niveau des meilleurs mondiaux
gilles à ce que tu es prêt et n'ont rien
dire mais la dure à huawei géant maître
chien compliquée mais qui sait la gauche
alors on va mais c'est trop dur ça va
être vraiment dur c'est trop dur ce qui
attention
ok c'est parti gilles verdez que je suis
un homme non non est-ce que je suis le
présentatrice noms d'actrices non une
chanteuse non pas politique française
oui est-ce que je suis connue très connu
oui oui ministre est ce que je suis et
riches n'ont pas une richesse que je
suis très pauvre connu pour être le bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais rajouter 10 secondes jeu altergo
gille c'était d'année je vais rajouter
10 secondes sur alger m 30 secondes qui
va le faire derrière ça se passe si vite
[Applaudissements]
kenny en 30 secondes
attention alors mikkeli attention recul
maxime jazzy maquillage assez d'une
critique elle connaît ses ebooks et bah
oui s'il vous plaît arrêtez arrêtez de
lombez thierry quétu va briller
allez allez attention que les balkany 30
secondes attention il fallait juste y
aller quel business chez un chanteur oui
justin bieber non moi je suis français
oui maintenant grands noms chanteur
français non
quels domaines hip hop
oui oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme comme elle a gagné elle a le droit
mais je dois dire que carrie ce sera
notre invité demain à tous les jours un
événement c'est jeudi on n'est jamais
tranquille
voilà on l'adoré c'est vrai que koné de
dakar ces batteries ba ba du loup je me
suis d'où je suis je regardais ce qui se
passe dans l'émission annonce assurée
merci j'ai trente secondes à la mine
soleil mais qui jetterait un des trains
n'ont pas tant les appâter des
attentions et par habitant à la place
des xi à voile et vient alors la nanon
romero mecheri en remettant sur quatre
secondes près notre esprit toile à lui
attribuant béchir et attention on joue
attention c'est parti top
est-ce que je suis un homme oui est-ce
que je suis un animateur oui est-ce que
je suis sur m6
non est-ce que sur tf1 mais je suis
vieux est-ce que je suis jeune oui oui
tamis combal non non est-ce que je suis
e s que je suis est juste que j'anime
des jeux wii
jean luc reichmann est ce que j'anime
adjani une des choses sur téva oui
j'anime des jeux sur tf1 dit manon
pardon non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle était dans une arène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez